THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY MOSTLY MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE BORDER PATROL
PUT THEIR LINES -- LIFE ON THE
LINE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
TEXAS SENATE GOVERNOR DAN
PATRICK, TEXAS STRANGERS HELPING
OUT BIG, BIG INSTANTS, LIKE 500
RANGERS CAME DOWN TO TRY TO
DISPERSE THE CARAVAN I KNOW
RECENTLY DAN.
YOU CAN FEEL THE FRUSTRATION ON
THE BORDER PATROL.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE, BUT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO -- THEY
ARE LIVID.
>> Dan: I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THEY ARE OVERWHELMED BECAUSE
THEY CAN HANDLE IT.
BUT EVERYTHING THEY CAN HANDLE
THEY ARE HANDLING.
BY THE WAY, WELCOME TO TEXAS.
WELCOME TO THE BORDER AND ALL
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE BACKGROUND
TRYING TO COME IN.
AND SO LET'S LOOK AT TAXES.
IN EL PASO WE ARE APPREHENDING
EL PASO 930 PEOPLE A DAY.
WE WILL APPROACH 1 MILLION
PEOPLE APPREHENDED THIS YEAR
PLUS ON THE BORDER FROM
CALIFORNIA TO BROWNSVILLE,
TEXAS.
I WAS TALKING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE OR FOUR.
>> Laura: 6,000 THEY THINK IN
THIS SECTOR ALONE HAVE BEEN GOT
A WAYS.
AND PROBABLY MORE THAN 6,000.
SO THE REAL NUMBER IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN 1 MILLION COMING IN.
>> Dan: THAT IS WHY I SAID TO
YOU WE HAVE CLOSE TO 10% OF THE
POPULATION HERE ILLEGALLY.
THERE WAS A POLL RECENTLY
152 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
WANT TO COME TO AMERICA AND
40 MILLION CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY ARE COMING.
LAST MONTH, LAURA, DEL RIO OF
THE SECTOR 12 YEARS AGO THIS
TIME WORKED IN THE BORDER PATROL
IN THE BUSHES AT NIGHT, AND AT
THAT TIME, MOSTLY SINGLE MALES
CROSSING.
LAST MONTH, WE HAD 30,000 SINGLE
MALES CAUGHT BUT 63,000
FAMILIES.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND HAS A RESET ON YOUR SHOW
BEFORE, THE DRUG CARTELS USE
THESE PEOPLE TO DISTRACT AND
TAKE UP TIME WITH THE BORDER
PATROL AND EVERYONE ELSE UP THE
MIDDLE.
>> Laura: THE DRUGS.
THE POLITICIANS IN WASHINGTON,
GIVE ME A COUPLE OF IDEAS,
SOLUTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL TALK ABOUT
POLITICIANS I SO CASTRO ON
EARLIER.
I COULD HEAR.
>> Laura: THEY WOULDN'T COME
ON.
THAT WAS A TAPE.
>> Dan: REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN TEXAS THE
REPUBLICANS COME DOWN TO SEE
THIS AND THE DEMOCRATS COME DOWN
HERE AND IGNORE IT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN
WASHINGTON.
NUMBER ONE WE HAVE TO CHANGE
ASYLUM LAWS AND NUMBER TWO, THEY
HAVE TO GIVE TROMP HIS MONEY
FENCING SO THIS IS HIGHER.
THIS IS BORDER CROSSING, BUT IN
THE AREAS OF NO-MAN'S-LAND, IN
FACT MUCH HIGHER AND MUCH
TOUGHER TO CLIMB.
SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE FENCING.
AND YOU HAVE TO GIVE BORDER
PATROL MORE ASSISTANCE.
BY THE WAY, TO THE DEMOCRATS,
GET OFF THEIR BACK.
THE STORY YOU WERE TELLING
EARLIER ABOUT THE YOUNG ONE WHO
DROWNED AND A NATURE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT.
YOU WERE ON THE RIVER TODAY.
YOU SAW THAT RAGING RIVER.
>> Laura: THE 21 DAYS, YOU'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO HOLD 21 DAYS.
WE HAVE ONE FEDERAL JUDGE.
ONE FEDERAL JUDGE, THAT ONE
JUDGE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MUCH OF
THIS CRISIS.
PEOPLE DYING, CHILDREN BEING
TEMPORARILY TOUGH TIMES BECAUSE
SOMEONE IS DOWN THE RIVER AND
ANOTHER UP THE RIVER SEPARATED.
LOOKING IN THE EYES OF THE
CHILDREN TODAY WAS A HEARTBREAK.
AS A MOTHER, IT IS A HEARTBREAK
FOR THE CHILDREN.
AND I ALSO HAVE HEARTBREAK FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE KIDS
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
OVERCROWDED -- I MEAN IT IS A
HEART BREAK TO SEE THIS
CHILDREN BEING USED.
>> Dan: I WAS ON YOUR SHOW IF
YOU WEEKS AGO AND IN CHARGE OF
MODERN-DAY SLAVERY TODAY.
BUT YOU SAW THIS.
THERE WERE ADULTS WITH CHILDREN
AND YOU COULD TELL THE CHILDREN
WEREN'T REALLY THEIR CHILDREN.
>> Laura: ONE IN PARTICULAR.
>> Dan: YOU KNEW
SEX TRAFFICKING.
AND THEY HAVE TO REALIZE THIS IS
A NATIONAL CRISIS AND NOT